[Música]
para muchos podría ser una decisión
completamente impensable pero la
coyuntura internacional actual ha
llevado a una pacifista alemania a
realizar una modificación a su
constitución una modificación que fue
aprobada ya por el bundestag el
parlamento alemán tras este cambio fue
posible facilitar una partida
extraordinaria de 100 mil millones de
euros para gasto militar a través de la
creación de un fondo la suma será
invertida en un plazo de cinco años y
busca reforzar las fuerzas armadas de
alemania la razón muy sencilla el
deterioro de la seguridad en europa
después de la invasión de rusia a
ucrania escuchamos las palabras del
canciller alemán olaf scholz haciendo
referencia a este tema si es
que el objetivo es un ejército alemán
capaz y moderno un ejército alemán capaz
de cumplir su objetivo central de
proteger al país y sus alianzas porque
está adecuadamente equipado la base y
repito lo que dije al principio el
descuido de 16 años de los ministros de
defensa de los partidos políticos
y cdu y su jefa de gobierno ahora eran
corregidos
así las cosas alemania entonces va a
destinar anualmente el 2 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto para el área
de defensa en cinco años se espera que
este país pase a ser la potencia militar
de europa y será según algunos analistas
expertos citados por financial times el
guardián de europa del este que tan
cierto puede ser esto lo vamos a ver en
unos minutos con nuestros analistas del
otro lado está rusia que criticó por
supuesto la creación del fondo militar y
lo consideró una remilitarización
una palabra que hace referencia al
período nazi y que fue usada por la
portavoz de la diplomacia rusa maría
sharapova con este panorama estamos
entonces ante una nueva línea de tensión
entre berlín y moscú cómo se va a
redistribuir entonces las cargas en
europa qué rol va a asumir alemania
tanto en la unión europea como al
interior de la otan estamos ante el fin
del pacifismo alemán la neutralidad de
suecia y finlandia y suiza estamos ante
una nueva configuración del continente
europeo alemania se rearma otro reto
para putin ese es nuestro tema de debate
en france 24 y para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a anna del paso analista
y profesora de la universidad
complutense de la ciudad de madrid a
quien le agradezco haber aceptado esta
invitación con tan poca antelación para
estar con nosotros también es en esta
conversación jesús manuel triana él es
analista de seguridad y defensa ambos
están en la ciudad de madrid en la
capital española pero ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación estamos a través de las
diferentes redes sociales con toda la
disponibilidad para que ustedes dejen en
los comentarios y preguntas relacionadas
con este tema extra ya lo saben estamos
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
también pueden ver nuestras señales en
streaming a través de youtube nos
encuentran como france24
santi logo que es 50 personal nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas relacionadas con este tema
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a anna muchas gracias ana por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y me
gusta llamar a la primera pregunta de
nuestro debate o de nuestro análisis
como el punto de partida y el punto de
partida es este histórico rearme que
significa para alemania y para europa
bueno como bien dices es histórico
porque está en la segunda guerra mundial
tengo que cambiar la constitución
alemana para qué
también aumenten sus efectivos y vuelvan
a hacer el servicio militar y
aumenten
en 100 mil millones de euros que es
bastante el 25 por ciento en su pib y
que va a ser paulatino no va a ser de
golpe va a ser en cinco años
su gasto de militar en defensa es
curioso que esto se lleva a cabo no sólo
por la invasión de rusia a ucrania sino
por también porque porque es tarde con
shorts y no con merkel que era bastante
se tendría bastante bien con putin y
preparaba bastante de los pies puesto
que ambos
vivieron en la república democrática
alemana y que alemania es la primera
potencia económica de la unión europea
se rearme es importante porque aún
siendo el miembro de la otan también es
de la unión europea no tanto
el reino unido con la salida del presi
entonces esto también hasta una cierta
independencia
militar
del lado de eeuu no quieres que sea malo
porque se pertenecer a la alianza
atlántica es bueno pero también nos da a
europa con el eje franco-alemán un
importante peso militar e independencia
habilitar que en todos los campos
le doy ahora la palabra de jesús manuel
también en la ciudad de madrid primero
los saludo y le agradezco por estar con
nosotros en el programa y punto de
partida para la discusión histórico
rearme lo que significa para alemania y
ya vamos a analizar lo que esto trae por
añadidura lo que significa para la unión
europea para el resto del continente y
por supuesto para las relaciones con
moscú
bueno yo creo que lo más significativo
todo esto es que hemos asistido a la
voladura han saltado por los aires las
ideas fundamentales con las que se
basaba la política hacia el este de
alemania la idea era cuanta mayor
interdependencia con rusia cuanto más
comercio de recursos energéticos
para habría un coste elevado para rusia
el romper las buenas relaciones con
occidente es decir que era una relación
que recibiera la dependencia con
energética hacia rusia el volumen del
negocio para rusia era suficientemente
significativo como para pensar que suele
frenaba esa idea pues ha quedado
absolutamente pues descartada después de
de la invasión rusa de ucrania y es más
nos plantea que el tabú de la guerra
convencional algo es un conflicto de
alta intensidad con ejércitos
convencionales chocando en el en el
frente de batalla por si se hará algo
que no habíamos visto en europa desde el
final de la guerra mundial quitando el
conflicto de la antigua yugoslavia que
tuvo sus particularidades con milicia
mails
y grupos irregulares más o menos en
aquellas naciones emergentes entonces
toda la idea de que los ejércitos en el
fondo aquí en europa pues no eran
necesarios en él sino que se tenían que
orientar hacia misiones de paz misiones
de mantenimiento de la paz en la en todo
el arco exterior de europa tanto el
mediterráneo oriente medio pues nos pone
a europa ante el espejo de las fuerzas
armadas de occidente de la europa
occidental no están a la altura de la
circunstancia los presupuestos han sido
escasos la operatividad en el caso de
alemanes siempre ha sido muy había
tenido enormes problemas de
disponibilidad de sus aviones de combate
sus carros de combate entonces por así
decirlo el conflicto de ucrania ha
puesto a europa ante el espejo ya le ha
obligado a comportarse como un adulto y
hacerse cargo de sus propias defensas
porque además siempre tuvimos bajo el
paraguas de atrás unidos siempre como un
pruebo problemas y pues en los balcanes
en los 90 o en libia en el 2011 y europa
quiso proyectar fuerza contó con eeuu
entonces esto es la el momento de la
verdad para europa y enfrentarse al
espejo de sus limitaciones y su y su
debilidad militar
anna esto podría generar un efecto de
bola de nieve digámoslo así en otros
países del continente europeo otros
países que decidan aumentar su gasto
militar ante la amenaza que puede
representar un avance ruso en ucrania
por ahora los combates y los ataques
están muy concentrados en el este de
ucrania pero ante movimientos como los
de suecia y finlandia que ya vamos a
mirar más adelante y también en la
posición de tropas de la otan en los
países del báltico puede llevar a que
otros países decidan bueno si alemania
lo hizo nosotros por qué no
bueno ahora vamos a matizar ciertos
aspectos
estamos hablando de europa o estamos
hablando de la otan porque de los 30
países de la otan miembros de la otan
el 10 de ellos
diez de ellos ya cumplen el 2% del pib
que no venía pidiendo no solo donald
trump sino para que obama que cumplían
el gasto el aumento del 2% del pib en
gastos de defensa entonces de los 30
países que son miembros de la otan y un
tercio es el único que que cumplía
habilitarán el pago de el gasto del 2
por ciento pero otros como por ejemplo
que es algo increíble que suene crecía y
aparte a pesar de tener un déficit de
increíble pues tiene un 38 82 82 por
ciento del pib en gasto en defensa por
encima de eeuu declaró
entonces si me preguntas si esto va a
producir una bola
de nieve pues ya se está produciendo
porque porque la industria de defensa
no sólo es el pib destinado al gasto de
defensa por ejemplo españa tiene está en
el penúltimo y en el penúltimo país de
gasto de defensa destinado de
correspondiente al pib pero sin embargo
somos los que más en misiones
internacionales participamos de la otan
y de la unión pero por ejemplo es
importante decir que en demasía pues
si se se invierte bastante dinero en el
industria de la defensa sí creo que
puede ser un
un aumento de las capacidades de defensa
y se permite es un minuto más pues te
diré que esto en la cumbre de madrid el
29 y 30 es uno de los temas que si la
revisión estratégica de la defensa
aunque se va a hacer ahora en madrid va
a incidir en el tema de que la defensa
es igual a paz y seguridad claro
jesús manuel su opinión sobre sobre este
tema sobre este efecto de bola de nieve
que puede haber en europa bueno la
cuestión del de la expansión
presupuestaria alemana lo que puede
servir es que se establezca una cláusula
que en este contexto muy particular
alemania siempre incidió en la
austeridad económica formaba parte de
ese grupo de países que
imponía aún algunos criterios de
austeridad en los presupuestos pues
ahora se establezca una excepción pero
si miramos el recorrido de los países
europeos desde el año 2014 vemos que
había una área muy concreta donde se
produjo una enorme expansión del gasto
de defensa después de la primera
invasión rusa de ucrania porque no
olvidemos que en el 2014 hubo una
invasión rusa en la que se ocupó la
península de crimea y eso produjo que
las tres repúblicas bálticas que polonia
que suez y que finlandia que en aquel
entonces no eran parte de la otan
expandieron su gasto entonces
este tirón de alemania se produce
después de ocho años en los que ha
habido una expansión del gasto de
defensa de los países de europa más
oriental lo que si para haber veremos
que tendrá puede como se plantea aquí
puede que tenga consecuencias en
bruselas en el que se haga una excepción
en los criterios de autoridad y que
según excepción con el gasto de defensa
si otros países siguen la línea y bueno
no tenemos problemas económicos color
con las consecuencias de la subida de
los de los commodities de los precios de
la energía y entonces en una situación
de recesión pues hagas excepción a los
criterios de austeridad y se considere
que si alemania pues se han saltado los
criterios de autoridad pues el resto
también se sentirá autorizado a hacer un
gesto hago la ronda la inversa continuó
con usted para preguntarle esto entonces
cómo cambia la percepción que tiene
alemania dentro del continente americano
dentro del continente europeo perdón
siempre ha sido visto como la maquinaria
económica del continente el país que
recibe a muchos migrantes por por la
industrialización que tiene por el
poderío económico que sostiene en la
unión europea y que como lo decía a nada
ese eje franco-alemán pues es
prácticamente el que está llevando las
riendas de la unión europea en cierta
forma y liderando un poco en los últimos
años aquí comienza a tomarle un poco
ventaja también a francia digámoslo así
o como lo ve usted aquí lo que se nota
es que ha habido una descompensación
enorme siempre entre lo que era el
poderío diplomático y económico la unión
europea y el poderío militar de ahí que
en la cumbre de la otan de septiembre
2014 en galés se estableciese ese
objetivo entre otras cosas porque esto
tiene que ver con el deseo
estadounidense de ir desenganchándose de
los asuntos de europa y de oriente medio
aquel y el famoso discurso de obama en
hawai en el año 2011 que decía que
quería pivotar su política exterior
hacia asia y lo vimos también y esto ya
no solamente es ha sido desde ucrania a
quizás haya abierto los ojos pero lo
vimos también en el tema de la retirada
occidental de afganistán que hubo una
cierta descoordinación de entre eeuu y
occidente porque la decisión la tomó
tornillo y aquí empezó a plantearse el
concepto en europa de autonomía
estratégica la cuestión es que para
tener esa autonomía estratégica y para
poder operar en los conflictos de la
periferia de europa hay que tener un
poderío militar entonces yo creo que
había un terrible taboo heredado de la
guerra mundial alemania se veía a sí
mismo como una potencia benévola que
pensaba que a través del comercio y la
interdependencia pues íbamos a vivir en
un mundo del fin de la historia
y lograr lo que vemos es que todos como
dimensión antes de los tabús han saltado
a mí de la sensación de que ahora
alemania porque vamos a verle tomar
decisiones y va a verle tomar un
protagonismo que no le habíamos visto
desde el fin de la guerra fría me parece
que sí evidentemente esto es como un
despertar una nueva toma de conciencia
de alemania de que tiene que tomar
decisiones duras y que las ideas con las
que se había concebido es el orden
europeo o se ha acabado
anna su opinión sobre este tema un
despertar de alemania una alemana una
alemania un poco más
activa a la hora de tomar decisiones y
no siendo como este país un poco bisagra
que siempre trataba la diplomacia y el
diálogo como su arma más fuerte para
moverse en la escena internacional junto
con su poderío económico ahora
incursiona en el área militar
bueno me
hace gracia que cita a la que su forma
franquismo por llamar de la historia
pero bueno a ver
vamos a ver la decisión de cambiar la
constitución y el rearme tal pues
se tomó justo tres días después de la
invasión de rusia y ucrania esto esto
hizo poner las alarmas en encendido a
alemania y fue un efecto dominó que
despertó a toda europa lo que otra cosa
es que nosotros en la opinión pública
nos hayamos enterado y entonces ellos o
sus servicios de inteligencia y tal
hacia la carga hacia hacia la opinión
pública para no alarmar para que no
hubiera un desasosiego y para que no vea
una
caída en las bolsas internacionales
etcétera un efecto dominó pues lo que
hemos dicho que lo que era un unas
maniobras en unos ejercicios con
bielorrusia y tal hacia las fronteras
pues a toda la inteligencia como se ha
visto luego pues
bajo mesa pues decía que iba a pasar lo
que ha pasado entonces el hecho de que
alemania tomase la decisión de aumentar
su presupuesto en defensa etcétera
etcétera tres días después de la
invasión a ucrania es lo que y que ha
rápidamente ya haya decidido cómo y en
qué gastos y qué partidas
presupuestarias van a ir a qué proyectos
que el primero va a ser en la luz va que
después de la armada después de los
sistemas de mando y control y luego e
incluso los satélites militares pues es
un proyecto de defensa bastante pensado
no es que sea mentalidad alemana es que
es como tiene que ser nosotros los
proyectos entonces qué pasa pues que
alemania
ya ha visto los dientes al lomo y
entonces las tuercas a 90 es que pasa
pues qué
como decía inicialmente es decir
no yo no tengo tan claro que esto se
quede aquí porque ya hemos visto que
de rusia de perdón de putin quiero
matizar de putin
no no no no no podemos no podemos
creernos nada nada y tan seco incluso
después de putin que puede pasar
entonces su sucesor es incluso peor el
que el con lo cual es una amenaza
potencial entonces que si antes de que
voy a estar los perdón ya estamos
hablando de transnistria ya estamos
hablando de moldavia e incluso de países
balcánicos afines a rusia con lo cual
sí pues alemania no se fía y es que
después de polonia en la frontera está
alemania tiene lugar nos hace claro es
ella músculo si enseña músculo ante la
amenaza de los de putin en este caso
aquí estamos viendo un
en el cierre podemos decirlo así no sé
qué piensa jesús de ese capítulo de el
pacifismo alemán también hace unas
semanas veíamos como la neutralidad
suiza prácticamente comenzaba a tomar un
bando al suiza determinar que aplicaría
algunas de las sanciones que impuso
también la unión europea a rusia hay
claramente toma un bando en la situación
y veíamos la postura de suecia y de
finlandia de dejar su neutralidad para
ingresar en la otan ante la amenaza que
ellos ven desde sus vecinos del oriente
hablando en este caso de rusia estamos
entonces ante un cambio histórico en el
continente europeo el fin del pacifismo
alemán el fin de la neutralidad de estos
tres países una postura
suiza un poco más digamos mojándose
tomando un poco de posición a nivel
político
desde luego que el caso del fin de la
neutralidad histórica de suiza y
finlandia pues yo creo que es que cada
vez que los estudios internacionales
hablaba de la neutralidad pues aparecen
yo creo que sí suiza como los dos casos
más significativos evidentemente la
distancia en geográfica de swiss al
exponer una situación diferente y como
mencioné antes es que desde el 2014
habían empezado a pasado ya bastantes
cosas en el báltico suecia recuperaba el
servicio militar finlandia hacia una
expansión del gasto militar para comprar
aviones cazas de quinta generación f-35
relativamente hace poco y además de todo
nos ponemos y nos ponen una paradoja y
es que si una de las razones
fundamentales de rusia para invadir
ucrania era neutralizar el país tratar
de crear un colchón que lo alejara las
fronteras de la otan pues él es uno de
los resultados inesperados de esta
guerra es que se multiplica por dos las
fronteras que rusia comparte con la otan
con la entrada de finlandia entonces
esto se empieza el orden ha cambiado por
completo nos la convivencia con rusia va
a ser totalmente diferente encima van a
ser una frontera caliente
que abarca desde el altico de la del
ártico y que llega hasta el mar negro y
bueno yo esto en su momento me parecía
que tenía visos de ser una nueva guerra
fría tanto por el desafío geopolítico y
por el desafío ideológico de una un
modelo alternativo que entroncaba aquí
en europa con los nacional populismo de
derechas con los que putin parece que se
lleva también entonces veremos uno
posiblemente veremos un telón de acero
pero si una línea una línea de
separación de bloques que lleva o que se
prolonga ahora desde el desde el ártico
hasta el mar negro y bueno vamos a ver
que si los rusos en ese objetivo de
dominar lo que es la costa de ucrania y
llegar a amoldar realizar la república
separatista de transnistria expande este
conflicto a otras regiones o sea que
esto evidentemente estamos en un nuevo
capítulo totalmente diferente han
saltado por los aires todas las obras
que se construyó la seguridad europea y
efectivamente sí señor un cambio
histórico
anna muy puntual le quiero preguntar por
la relación que pueda tener en este
momento y que pueda llegar a tener oa
desarrollarse en las próximas semanas
entre moscú y berlín desde la
reunificación
alemania y rusia han tenido muy buenas
relaciones usted mencionaba el caso
ángela merkel cuando era canciller de
alemania era prácticamente la única que
podía hablarle al oído a vladimir putin
y frenarlo un poco y sentarlo en
cintura un poco para tratar los temas
internacionales será la interlocutora
ideal para occidente para tratar con
putin no habiendo un interlocutor
similar y ante esta escalada de tensión
entre los dos países que puede pasar
entre berlín y moscú
bueno antes quería salir a hablar de
finlandia
esta pregunta un paréntesis vigilancia
por de ross tras una mundial
rusia quito un tercio del territorio de
finlandia entonces ahora ha perdido
su
neutralidad los únicos que quedan
neutrales son austria y
en ustedes grande ya veremos qué pasa y
volviendo a tu pregunta qué interesante
pregunta y después de tantos todas estas
mesas del silencio de cien días de
guerra de días de guerra habló el otro
día y dijo que no estaba bien lo que
había hecho que debería de replegarse
devolver los terrenos no replantearse lo
que la agresión
que estaba absolutamente de acuerdo con
todo con todas las respuestas que había
dado la otan y la unión europea y shorts
entonces bueno
merkel supongo yo que
evidentemente ya que quiero tomar un
papel cuando dejó la política dejó la
política absolutamente lo dejó claro
pero
no creo que iba a interferir pero el que
el hecho de que haya hablado después de
100 días desde en ucrania es un toque de
atención a putin de que la línea roja ha
pasado y por consiguiente si rusia va a
pretende seguir en un enfrentamiento ya
va a ser y una invasión más allá de
ucrania no vamos no creo yo yo descarto
y toco madera
que se atreva creo que porque ya sería
y face to face contra contra contra la
otan y desde luego ni tiene recursos
económicos y tiene recursos militares
estratégicos y de ni-ni efectivos
militares suficientes y lo hemos visto
con los fallos estratégicos tácticos y
de sus fuerzas militares si bien entre
eso es lo que están tratando ahora que
van a poner sobre el negro sobre blanco
en la nueva revisión estratégica defensa
porque ahora rusia ha cambiado ahora ese
es su papel es agresivo claro jesús en
la ciudad de madrid en la relación moscú
berlín que puede pasar entre estos dos
países y cómo podría reaccionar un país
tan impredecible o por lo menos un
presidente tan impredecible como
vladimir putin que un día dice no vamos
a invadir ucrania
dos semanas después estaban las tropas
en el este de ucrania
bueno la relación se había basado en esa
interdependencia de la que yo había
mencionado y que estaba cimentada entre
otras cosas con que había altos cargos
antiguos altos cargos así porque
empezando por un ex canciller gerhard
schroeder que estaban a sueldo de moscú
entonces esas relaciones que estaban
cimentados con toda la existencia de un
ex político alemán está haciendo
prácticamente la labor del lobby en el
sentido y se había construido aquí ya
que la angela merkel a la gran canciller
constructora de de una estabilidad
alemana resulta que es pues la
arquitecta de este modelo de
interdependencia que fue la que apostó
después de la invasión rusa de crimea en
el 2014 por consolidar la interna
independencia energética a través del
gasoducto nostián 2 que atraviesa el
báltico entonces esa relación no
solamente era la de iguales sino que
había una acción de influencia rusa
operando en alemania y que ahora se ve
cuestionada hubo dimisiones entre
algunos de esos ex políticos trabajando
para empresas rusas y entonces me parece
que
la capacidad de influencia y de generar
esas conexiones con alemania pues ahora
mismo está absolutamente cuestionada y
me parece que las tensiones las
relaciones van a ser bastante tensas se
encuentra imprevisibilidad pues bueno
evidentemente las declaraciones rusas
negaban que fuesen a invadir pero los
expertos que estaban siguiendo la
doctrina y el pensamiento ruso y las
ideas planteadas por rusia anunciaron
que esta guerra se estaba cocinando que
hacía un año y no al menos a ese pequeño
reducido grupo de expertos sobre
pensamiento estratégicos rusos no les
pilló por sorpresa en absoluto es decir
las declaraciones rusas fueron parcos
totalmente ajeno a sus verdaderas
intenciones
jesús hablemos de la otan está alianza
internacional la alianza del atlántico
norte está alianza militar que papel
entonces pasará a tener alemania a raíz
de esta inversión millonaria que va a
ser en su defensa pasará a tener un
papel mucho más
predominante mucho más de liderazgo será
como dice el financial times el guardián
de europa del este como cree que va a
cambiar el posicionamiento de alemania
dentro de la alianza
bueno hay una cosa que me parece muy
significativa y suecia y finlandia ya
eran miembros de la unión europea que
supuestamente tiene también
responsabilidades de seguridad pero
cuando tuvimos la invasión rusa de
ucraniano se reforzó el los mecanismos
europeos de defensa a donde acudieron
finlandia y suecia esa una alianza en la
que el principal socio es eeuu esto nos
da una cierta idea de que los países que
están en primera línea frente a los
rusos de quien realmente se fían es de
eeuu como garante de su soberanía y de
hecho es una de las grandes cuestiones
para la expansión de la otan o sea una
organización liderada por eeuu hasta sus
territorios más las antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas su área de influencia a
lituania letonia estonia entonces
mientras podemos pensar que
efectivamente está este aumento esta
pensión del gasto de alemania nos lleva
a una alemania más asertiva que se tome
más en serio las cuestiones de defensa
esto no deja de operar dentro de una
organización que está liderada por eeuu
y ojos que mucho de esa ayuda de verdes
pero no ayuda no dice gasto de mil
militar alemán se va a orientar hacia
comprar tecnología estadounidense a la
hora de la verdad los de alemania pues
ya estaba planteándose que ellos quieren
seguir con la doctrina de poder operar
armas nucleares de forma compartida y
para poder lanzar esas armas nucleares
necesitan aviones construidos en eeuu y
eso significaría por ejemplo la compra
de aviones de quinta generación es de 35
los aviones de patrulla marítima se
hagan a olvidado por completo del
programa europeo entonces aunque podamos
pensar que esta expansión de alemania y
este mayor protagonismo de alemania le
va a dar una posibilidad a europa de ser
un actor más relevante de forma autónoma
no deja de ser dentro del contexto de
una alianza liderada por eeuu y con un
protagonismo del las conexiones de
compras de tecnología militar que siguen
manteniendo el eje euro atlántico
anna entonces con este panorama como
vemos entonces el tema de defensa dentro
de la unión europea como lo explicaba
jesús suecia y finlandia lo primero que
hicieron fue acudir a la otan no acudir
a la unión europea ese bloque al que ya
pertenecen vuelve a quedar otra vez
sobre la mesa esa necesidad de europa de
tener mejores mecanismos de defensa más
allá de esta alianza que es liderada por
eeuu
perderme que haga una matización a jesús
adelante
es cierto que va a comprar un
f-35 a
eeuu hombre es el mejor avión que hay en
el mercado y yo no yo no trabajo para la
empresa y no voy haciéndome empresa pero
pero a ver la luz con fe es que tiene
aviones vamos todas todas donde sube
tierra la armada para comprar
helicópteros
submarinos tiene que modernizar todos
esos momentos de acuerdo porque las
misiones en las que participaba eran de
munición rival de observación etcétera
de acuerdo entonces
como no va a comprar entre 35 americanos
no es claro pero va a comprar
ya lo quisiera turquía pero es la misma
esta del proyecto eurofighter y el
eurofighter es un proyecto de avión para
los que no estén especializados de su
proyecto europeo entonces en fin no sé
y además no sé
no no no va a ser dependiente de eeuu va
a comprar lo mejor entonces y lo más
rápido entonces
y además el que compre en la industria
estadounidense no quiere decir que sea
dependiente de estados unidos para
comprar y punto esto es como cuando vas
a la cesta la compra y entonces turquía
también quiere f-35 y turquía está
demostrando que no es dependiente de
eeuu
en cuanto a tu pregunta
volviendo a esto yo creo que sí que
alemania va a tener un papel importante
en europa y en eeuu siempre lo he tenido
no porque ahora sea solo pero cuando
acordaros que cuando merkel
efectivamente no era la canciller
alemana que era la canciller europea y
de nada que cortaba el bacalao y era la
que la que
movía las fichas del tablero europeo
estratégico y geopolítico
y se comía todos a cuantos en
presidentes de gobierno hasta así es que
ha estado casi tanto tiempo como los 70
años de la reina isabel de inglaterra
que la hemos visto ahora en el latino
entonces vamos a ver es importante que
ahora siga una sincronía y una un
acuerdo entre francia y alemania en
antiguos enemigos durante la primera
guerra mundial el entendimiento es
fundamental
pero en ese caso en ese orden de ideas
cómo queda la unión europea que vuelve
poníamos el ejemplo de suecia y
finlandia que acudieron primero a la
otan antes de buscar
soluciones o respuestas o apoyo dentro
de la unión europea vuelve a quedar ese
tema de la defensa de la unión europea
débil y esto me encanta que me hagas
tanto vamos a ver
el artículo es 5 de la otan s
es defensa colectiva es decir si tú me
atacas a mí yo si rusia me ataca a
españa yo pongo yo pongo a disposición
lo que pueda pero el anticuado 40 de la
unión europea que decir que sí o sí te
tengo que defender como sea es decir es
más vinculante que la defensa colectiva
en la unión y siendo miembro de la unión
europea artículo 38 39 40 eso es más
vinculante el artículo estos tres
artículos de la línea europea que de la
otan con lo cual es como un poco
redundante si encima eres miembros de la
unión europea y de la otan ya sí o sí
tienes que que alguien se va a ayudar
claro entonces
finlandia ha dicho bueno vale yo estoy
de lado yo soy pero pero por si las
moscas también la unión europe de la
otan porque precisamente porque ya un
tercio del territorio como he dicho
antes se lo comió como fue fue
robado e invadido igual que pasa ahora
con él lo que está pasando con el
donbass por por rusia en ucrania
entonces ha dicho soy voy a [__] y
vuelva a hacer
de la otan claro
sí ha quedado claro importante ese punto
esos esos artículos vinculantes tanto de
la otan como en la unión europea me
queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa les doy 30 segundos a cada uno
para que hagan su conclusión rápidamente
qué va a suceder con todo este anuncio
de alemania y ésta
refuerzos que va a ser de sus fuerzas
militares comienzo con jesús adelante
bueno pues esto de la expansión del
gasto de fe es algo que se había
planteado como objetivo del 2014 entra
dentro del contexto de una eterna
persecución europea de una cosa que se
llama autonomía estratégica pero ahora
habrá que ver qué intereses más allá de
la del este hirsig si ese funk eje
franco-alemán se pondrán de acuerdo para
que este nuevo poderío alemán sirva de
herramienta para una política exterior
común que es el gran problema nunca nos
ponemos de acuerdo los europeos muy bien
si tenemos una herramienta militar que
gente la vamos a usar porque tenemos
seis intereses divergentes elsa elisa
francia-alemania dirá a europa del este
si jesús
gana su conclusión rápidamente por favor
muy puntual
pues yo creo que es una buena noticia
segundo
la tenía obsoleta con lo cual se ha
puesto las pilas puede ser de proyección
no sólo emisiones de paz y dietas sino
también de proyección que por eso lo
estamos haciendo nosotros y segundo va a
poner también el apoyo en la industria
militar europea con lo cual va a ser
general para
generar puestos de trabajo e impulsar la
industria europea pues ha ganado el paso
ya jesús manuel triana en la ciudad de
madrid les agradezco por haber hecho
este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 en américa latina' ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus preguntas y
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales y pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]